so in this video i'm gonna be answering
a pretty common question do i need to be
good at math to become an architect math
is involved in every step of an
architecture project and i'd say it does
play a pretty big part in turning a
concept into a real building but while
architects do use math on a daily basis
it's not exactly in the way that most
people think
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the channel my
name is dami and i'm an architect in
beautiful vancouver bc and today we're
going to talk about a couple different
ways we use math to design buildings and
make them come to life this video is
sponsored by autodesk click on the
description to get a free 30-day trial
probably the most common use of math for
us is when calculating the area so
whether we're designing a new building
or renovating an existing space we need
to show the client how much area we're
creating or gaining or losing because if
this math doesn't work out chances are
the project won't go through so you get
the overall gross floor area of the
building by multiplying the building's
length and width and then for each space
that you create within the building but
most architects these days use a bim
modeling system and uh personally i use
revit and actually the modeling software
does most of these basic calculations
for you meaning you
most likely never have to measure
dimensions or calculate areas by hand
however we do still manually calculate
certain things like when we're massing
up the building
the building's massing or the form is
driven by what we call a floor space
ratio and pretty much every real
building that you design
starts with this constraint most cities
or jurisdictions will have regulations
and guidance on how big or how dense or
how tall you can build on a particular
site this basically ensures that you
don't get any buildings that are totally
out of scale from its context typically
every property has what you call a floor
space ratio or fsr for short and that's
a number it's a ratio of a building's
total gross floor area to the size of
the land that the building's on so this
measures the density of the site and in
order for you to figure out how much
floor area you can build you take the
area of your site
and multiply it by the fsr so let's say
your property is 45 meters by 35 meters
and that would be
1575 square meters
and let's say you have an fsr of
3.03 that means you can build up to 47
25 square meters where it becomes kind
of interesting is when you combine this
with other constraints for your project
it can be legal constraints like
setbacks or height limits
or it can be physical constraints like
views or topography or soil conditions
or it could even be budgetary
constraints for example maybe the client
only has money to build one story of the
building
so taking all of this into consideration
you massage the massing of the building
however
if this is a commercial building owner
like a developer this whole thing is
pretty straightforward they're going to
want to maximize the fsr so that they
can build more
and they can sell more units so that
they can make more profit so let's go
back to my example for a sec the 45 by
35 meter site with the fsr of 3 and the
gfa of 47.25 square meters and let's say
your zoning regulations say you need to
set back 6 meters at the front and 2
meter on the sides the building's
footprint is going to get smaller
meaning if you want to achieve that 47
25 square meters you're gonna have to go
taller and from here you can determine
the height and the number of stories for
your building you're also going to want
to factor in any neighboring buildings
or view corridors or trees or anything
that might suggest a different shape for
your building you also want to factor in
the market unit sizes we want to make
sure that the units we're creating is
kind of in the ballpark of what's
marketable for the developer so as
you're sculpting your building based on
some of these constraints you're gonna
be adjusting these areas as well now if
your zoning has a height limit or
setback that doesn't allow you to do
what you want that's when you get into
negotiations with the city into a
process called rezoning all these
setbacks and rules are guidelines but if
you can make a really strong argument
for why your building can benefit the
neighborhood by deviating from this
guideline the city or the township if
they're open-minded is going to want to
work with you to help you make this
happen and they're going to do this by
helping you re-zone the site with a
different set of rules all of this
requires you to do some basic math um
and most of it can be done with a
calculator or a simple spreadsheet one
of the other misconceptions about
architects is that we work alone and
that we are these lone creatives
drafting late into the night but
we simply can't do our work without
collaborating with other professionals
bim collaborate pro is a tool that makes
this process a lot more efficient with
the ability to seamlessly coordinate
your model with your team within a very
secure common data environment it makes
it easy to give feedback resolve issues
and just get a better overall view of
your project so that your team can stay
on track together by connecting your
model with models from other disciplines
it automatically detects where clashes
could happen and it helps you resolve
them typically the architect is
responsible for manually coordinating
these elements but this is way more
accurate and it saves us a lot of time
issues can be marked directly in the
model which is then turned into a simple
list that you can work through this
means that you can easily leave notes or
comments directly in the model so that
you or your team can resolve it and
nothing gets missed click on the
description to get a free 30-day trial
so the next area where we use math is
for high level budgeting or costing so
when we design buildings we want to make
sure that we're not designing something
that's going to be insanely expensive so
we will typically have check-in points
throughout the project with a cost
estimator to make sure that we're kind
of in the ballpark of the client's
budget and we do costing at different
points of a project and they get more
and more detailed as we progress the
design for example we'll do one at the
schematic design stage we'll also do one
at the design development stage and
we'll do one after the construction
documents as we fine-tune the costing
we go through the list and try to
identify areas that could
be a cost savings to the client and that
can range from
changing the structure or the shape of
your building
if it's earlier on in the project all
the way down to the finishes that you
pick and although the costing of the
building is done by a cost estimator the
architect does review all of those
numbers
and make sure that
all of those areas that they've
calculated based on are the correct
areas they are specialists in what they
do so typically they know what's best
and they know what they're costing but
sometimes you might have found a product
that kind of does the same job but it's
like half the cost and in that case you
can recommend that to the cost estimator
this is also just pretty basic
multiplication and
just learning to use spreadsheets
and finally structure so when people
think about math and architecture
typically they think about architects
calculating structural loads but in
reality
we don't really do that
and even if we wanted to
i don't think insurance companies would
like that very much because architects
already take on so much liability for
other work so typically
we work with structural engineers who
design the structure and they take on
that responsibility and that liability
for the calculations for us it's more
about the high level understanding of
structures and having some basic
conceptual framework for what we're
designing and we just need to focus on
areas that have an impact on the design
for example if you wanted to design the
building to cantilever you know that
it's going to need some beefy structural
members under here so make sure you
leave some room for that you also want
to make sure your walls are aligned to
the structural grids as much as possible
or maybe you want to use
exposed wood beams for aesthetic or
sustainability purposes once you have
those ideas you just work with your
structural engineer to find the exact
sizing and spacing of those members and
the overall system
so this is generally the extent of how
we use math in our day to day but
we do
borrow a lot of mathematical principles
for design for example the golden ratio
angles and proportions
and understanding these principles is
gonna make you a better architect and a
designer so i hope this gave you guys
some insights into how we use math it's
really not a lot of math and it should
never be the thing that hinders you from
going into architecture however there
are specific skills that you should
consider before going into architecture
and if you're interested in learning
about those check out my video right
here i also have a video where i talk
about the realities of going into
construction and other skills that would
help you become a more successful
architect i'll leave that video right
here as well i also have a monthly
newsletter where i share my insights
things i'm learning reading or listening
to
as well as a discord channel where you
can chat with other people in this
amazing community if you want to support
the channel and listen in on interviews
by me with other industry professionals
as well as access to other perks i have
membership tiers that you can join and
i'll leave links to all of this in the
description of the video and with that
i'll see you guys in the next video
[Music]
you